okay josh hello hello
iet canada how you doing hey we love you
over here at et canada
um i love canada
where are you are you are you on the
western east coast you're in toronto i
assume right
you know what i live in la and i just
came to toronto
and uh this is where i'm from so
toronto great city i've got a lot of
good friends there
it's a really really good town ah i love
that
i do the t dot that's what i call it the
t dot do they call it the t
or do i just call it the t dot i mean we
call it the six now but we'll take
whatever you're given josh
[Laughter]
oh my god so let's talk about a way um
you know your character has dreams of
going into space
um and then those dreams get put on hold
because of a medical diagnosis
and then you support your wife um how
important was it for this series to have
a woman taking charge as the commander
uh you know i i i you know i think it's
it's the story that they're telling and
i think it's great to have a strong
heroic female character
at the center of it um yeah you know i
think it was a really smart decision
uh yeah the two characters are you know
both trained to be astronauts and
emma and matt and that's how they met
and fell in love and
we're not for matt's medical condition
he you know may have very well been on
this mission as well or on another
mission
so i think he does have a lot of regrets
about not being able to
go to space which is the ultimate
objective of any astronaut
but given that he is an engineer and has
an engineering background as opposed to
emma who is a pilot
he was able to stay in the fold at nasa
and reinvest himself and he's been such
an instrumental part
as a chief engineer at nasa and putting
the mission together so he feels very
much
connected to it and i think he's so
thrilled for his wife
to be leading this mission in this
historic mission
would you ever be interested in going to
mars
and if so what is one thing you'd bring
yeah i don't know about mars that sounds
a little far but i would love to go to
the moon
the moon sounds cool when uh doing
research for this show i got to go to
nasa for a couple days in houston and
uh got to get on the argos machine which
makes you weightless and that was really
cool to send those videos to my son and
then they took me into a vault where you
put on these bunny suits and
go through these different chambers and
then i got to touch you know through the
plastic but tons of the moon rocks from
all the apollo missions and see them
through microscopes and that just seeing
that and the documentaries i've seen
of the the later apollo missions the
guys you know moon buggy
across the moon that looks incredibly
fun to me
so yeah that i would do mars i don't
know i mean
that sounds like a real that's too far
for me
uh is there one item in particular you
would bring
if you i mean music just music you know
i mean i don't know
something make sure that i have access
to uh
you know i don't know if if the
streaming services work uh from mars i'm
not sure if they'll have the internet
set up by then but
uh so maybe an ipod or something that
can play all the
music because i like all different kinds
of music so yeah
um you and your relationship uh the
marriage
you know on the show the relationship
with hillary swank uh
what was that like on set oh it's great
i mean you know we spend so much time on
this first season in particular you know
away from each other no pun intended uh
but we started filming the the series
with a lot of the
the stuff on earth uh and so we got to
build that foundation both
you know hillary and myself and talitha
bateman who plays our daughter
alexis and uh doing that and rehearsing
and photo shoots and being able to sort
of
you know form a a bond uh
it came really naturally really really
uh easily for me
i think hillary is a big part of why i
wanted to do the project was to work
with her
uh and ed i think she's a fantastic
actor
um you know very strong committed uh
you know and incredibly just you know
incredibly nuanced and
i was i was excited to to work with her
and it definitely uh
it uh it was it was definitely great